each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
good afternoon everyone I'm happy to
welcome the University of Washington's
division of design today they'll be
presenting some student projects from
their art for 8 for class on health and
wellness there's an interaction design
class that spanned the last 10 weeks and
this class this year is part of the the
Microsoft research design Expo which is
a program that Microsoft Research is
leading to encourage outstanding Design
Thinking worldwide and this year we
decided to partner very closely with
ours the University of Washington and
what is nice about that is that we're
actually able to bring in all the
students and let them show their their
projects here at in Redmond there'll be
more presentations later on this summer
as part of the faculty summit and you'll
see projects they are from from Brazil
China Hong Kong and other places in the
world but today we're spent I'm asking
you to do a special welcome for the
University of Washington here so I'll
ask professor axel Ressler to come up
first and introduce the class and give
you basic outline of what this class was
about excellent maybe in your pocket
good afternoon my name is all right now
we can't part okay my name is axel Rosa
I'm a professor for interaction design
at the division of design University of
Washington it's a new program we started
out in fall 2005 and our idea is to
create a base at the University of
Washington where design students can
work with students from all across
campus working in technical disciplines
and human-computer interaction focus and
we are also a member of the duck group
on University of Washington so it's a
very interdisciplinary group computer
science technical writing information
school psychology that meets weekly on
Wednesdays 12 o'clock so there's this
dub group event every week and I think
what's really interesting with this
class is that we have a broad spectrum
of stew
not only do we have students from
diverse disciplines such as the design
fields namely visual communication and
also industrial design design studies
but also technical communication from
the informatics program at the I school
from Electrical Engineering we have
professional students and graduate
students junior seniors all mixed
together what is also interesting with
this class is that we had a very close
connection with Georg and who brought in
several members from Microsoft research
and Microsoft campus that has really
close interactions with the students and
gave us really tremendous feedback on
every step in the process which was very
focused on research and studying user
behavior working on ideation and then
come up with mock-ups that we could test
prototypes to really then phase it out
in detailed prototypes for the final
presentation so today we're going to
show you what the outcome was of this
project and we have six teams ranging
from team sizes from two to six so we
were very experimental there too and the
team formation and project
identification and hope you are going to
enjoy the presentation and I want to
thank Georg and Microsoft for their
generous support and time and resources
and also the hard work of the students
that make this event today possible
thank you thank you very much like so
start it off we have team of first years
were five right team of five called
pebble in the pond and we're very
excited to be here we just want to thank
Microsoft research team for giving us
this opportunity to present our design
or a multidisciplinary group consisting
of visual communication design
information science industrial design
and informatics and I'm just going to
jump right into it and give you a brief
summary of our of just identifying first
our problem and then introducing our
design of the solution and so uh what we
found is that people as grocery sock
shoppers are the face with a variety of
options in deciding what products to
purchase and up it's really difficult to
get a sense of how they differ in terms
of their health attributes and
environmental impacts and so what we've
designed is solution to this project
this problem is uh is what we call fit
to shop and that is a web it's a
web-based tool that gives a
visualization of these differences
enabling consumers to compare products
make the best choices and then it
compiles their decisions into a shopping
list and additionally this interface
records the user shopping history and
creates visualizations for that as well
so I'm just going to hand it off to
Kevin and he's gonna elaborate on how we
got to where we are right now all right
so you guys you guys kind of guys kind
of wonder you know where do products
come from hardly processed what kind of
energy did it take to really get it to
where it was to you and how you consumed
it and what happens after you dispose of
the product and so what we did was we
looked at the kinds of situations where
people make these decisions when they
buy these everyday products and what are
the consequences of these everyday
transactions that you experience with
and so we went out into the environment
and did some observations to see how the
customers and the shoppers engage in
their surroundings we looked at the
grocery store in particular to see what
kind of signage was there what kind of
information is already available and
what kind of situation that were in
contextually and we found that they
don't have a lot of time attention or
the free hand to really engage in any
kind of technology that we want to
incorporate we want to keep it
hands-free and make it easy for them to
kind of use the resources around them
such as a shopping list which we
discovered was a very useful tool that
they use as a way to refer and recall
the items that they need to buy for
their necessity and as a way to just
offload kind of that cognitive memory
load and so we thought about where do
they make these decisions and with the
shopping list they do it at home when
they think about in their kitchen what's
there what's in their pantry and as
they're writing things down they use
that to record all their needs and to
make those decisions about what's
healthy for themselves their children
and considering what might be the impact
of the product that they buy and so we
also thought grocery stores were
particularly important because for every
household one-third of their involved
environmental impact it comes from those
everyday food and beverages that we
consume so we thought this was a huge
opportunity to really make change to put
people in the driver's seat of making
those decisions and to really encourage
that kind of activity because we just
need to and so Marilyn's going to kind
of show you the interactions that happen
with our design through the story of
Sophie meet Sophie Sophie's a 51 year
old chemist she's a resident of Seattle
she lives in a condo with her cat Felix
and is a avid gardener in terms of her
attitudes towards health in the
environment she's a very healthy eater
she's very aware of nutritional concepts
and concerned about her health in terms
of her environmental attitude she feels
good about contributing to the curbside
recycling Pro program but she's not
somebody who actively seeks out
environmental information and if she has
product project product choices she'll
tend to choose the one that cost less
rather than the one that's marked
environmentally friendly and we
intentionally chose someone like Sophie
as our prototypical user because when we
when we described this project idea to
potential users those who were already
more environmentally aware we're very
excited about it it was an easy sell
but we wanted to be sure that a bra
audience was a little broader than that
so we talked to people like Sophie who
care about the environment but aren't
necessarily actively doing making
changes in their behavior and when we
talk to these people we - two important
things came up one was that they liked
the idea of this product but if it gave
them too much negative information and
made them feel guilty they would tend to
avoid it so we needed to present the
information in a fairly positive way and
and the other one was that they didn't
want a system telling them what to do or
what to buy they wanted to be given
options so that we took those into
consideration with our design so okay so
Sophie has read about about fit to shop
and she decides to check it out so this
is what she sees when she goes there
first the the page is dominated by this
graph that has health axis along the
side and an environmental axis along the
bottom she notices the search but box up
there and one of the things she's
planning to buy today at the store is
tomato soup so she types in tomato soup
runs a search and sees two things happen
first of all there are nine types of
tomato soup soup available in her store
and they're ranked here by price and
then they also populate the grid so what
she's seeing here is that there's a
fairly wide range of differences in
health and differences in environmental
impact between these products so she's
curious to find out what is this one
that's way up the top that's high on the
health scale and high on the
environmental scale it turns out that
Amy's are a chalky organic and not
surprisingly it's one of the more
expensive options and then she also sees
these bars appearing that help her
understand how it achieves that ranking
so it's high in vitamin A vitamin C
she's a little unsure what some of these
mean so she can hover over them and see
the detail so for example the a is
indicating that Amy's corporation was
given an A grade for their corporate in
and for their environmental and social
policies and and behaviors okay so she
wants to learn more say how Amy's
compares with some of the cheaper option
so you can click on the info button and
get some more details about each of
these products and then it's even easier
to compare a prop lacrosse product so
for example she can see that while these
other two have provide 10% of your
vitamin C requirement for the day Ami's
provides 40% and it also provides 20% of
your vitamin A so so there is a
significant a significant difference and
then when she's decided which purchase
she wants to make she can click on one
of these plus symbols and that appears
over in her shopping list
so she can continue on explore more more
products and when she's ready she can
print it out and take the list of the
store with a record of the decisions
she's made ok so that's one aspect to
fit the shop this is the page that helps
you make decisions about products but
there's also a history aspect as Kevin
mentioned since she uses a membership
card when she Shops at her store her
actual purchases are being recorded and
they're reflected in her history page so
there are there are actually two panels
of the history page this is the health
panel later on we'll see the environment
panel and so she can see here how she's
doing generally what the trends are and
down here she sees a food pyramid and
she can see how well her product
purchases are aligning with with the
food pyramid recommendations now
Sophie's been very busy in the last
month and she's been buying a lot of
convenience foods and shows she's
concerned that maybe she hasn't been
eating quite as healthy as usual so
she's clicked on the 30-day view and she
can see that indeed her the balance of
her products is a little off but and she
can see where she needs to cut down and
where she needs to eat more okay she
goes to the environment tab she sees a
similar display again she can get a
sense of how she's doing I didn't point
out before that she can also see where
the average American is so she can see
how she's doing compared to the average
American and again she she has some
details here in this case for example
this first one is telling her when she
buys paper products what percentage of
the
products have recycled content and again
so this is her and this is the average
American she can see that she was doing
better than the average American and she
can also actually get details she can
see exactly what she purchased so that's
fit the shop and that's Sophie um after
a while she you know this this is more
time-consuming obviously than just
scribbling down a shopping list but
she's learning each time she uses it and
just just the fact that she's have been
exposed to this has raised her awareness
so now I'll pass it back to Kevin to to
summarize finish up for us alright so
basically what we aim to do was to help
the consumer and the shopper become more
informed and educated because from
really our user research the target
audience if granted they have more
education their will they do turn into
those proactive people who make more
smarter decisions and who will
ultimately drive you know companies to
realize that this is something that
needs to happen because the consumers
are responding this way this can be
shared with others and this just
empowers the user to make those better
decisions every day some of the
considerations that we also made aside
from the system was a second component
much similar to how target has price
scanners we thought of a way to allow
them to scan products in store in case
there was a gap in remembering what they
were researching why this product was
important or maybe there was a new
product that just came out at the key of
C or the Whole Foods and they want to
learn more about it than in there
because maybe something at the same
price could be more beneficial for their
children at home and another important
aspect that we wanted to incorporate was
to in the future involve more social and
communal activities because again from
user research we found that
environmental and health activities were
very social these were activities that
people shared and related with not
because of it makes them healthy but
because it's an experience that they can
participate with other people outside of
their usual social network and so we
wanted to somehow think about ways we
can expand our system to be
accommodating for that kind of activity
in the real world and so ultimately I
want to visualize help empower people
give them choice be sent
about that choice and that's it that's
fit to shop so so the whole skill we
actually used a system that's been
developed by nutritionists that that
gives each each food item and sorry I
forgot to repeat the question the
question was how are these these
measurements made because of class
a database that has classifications for
a reasonable subset so that your system
becomes useful because you on most of my
career cited lines
I'm not going to use it right but United
something like that Wikipedia where it
can
how do we get data for data about
environmental and health impacts for a
significant so how do we how do we
gather the data about the health and
environmental impacts for a significant
enough number of products that people
don't get that people get data when they
go searching
so there are impressively comprehensive
databases out there for for health
health indexes for each item and my
understanding of the way these are
derived is basically it has to do with
nutritional density so for a given
product you know how what how many
nutrients per calorie or per volume each
each item has so that that allows you to
put very different foods on a lot on a
common scale and in my experience with
it it's a very comprehensive database so
I I'd you know hopefully there wouldn't
be too many gaps so the environmental
one that's different there's a lot of
information out there it took a lot of
time to gather it but it's there but
there's also obviously a very active and
interested community out there so I do
envision that with an infrastructure in
place there would be contributors to it
to create a database like that
yes oh yeah so the question was how many
computers are there and on average in a
household in the kitchen in the US or
anywhere so how many homes did we look
at or if we looked at had computers yeah
so did we look at it did we investigate
how many homes have computers and we did
not look at that information list is in
their kitchen and when you think of
something you go write it down you don't
want to have to go to the other room and
and work on this and so we're
envisioning that I mean we consider
things like scanning your listing you
know that you've made in the kitchen and
I think really how this would work it
would be a combination of first of all
if you've used this system for a long
time you'll start to know what your
decisions were you don't have to look at
tomato soup every time and if you buy
tomato soup a lot you've already decided
so we just think that will work
but but that that that is an issue I
don't yeah that's an issue we thought
about it we're hoping it's not too much
oh yeah well I think you had your hand
up for all
so the question was did we think about a
business model essentially that could be
used to generate money and that was a
discussion we've had as a group and with
our professor and we think that you
could incorporate maybe a point system
to encourage people to buy more organic
foods because they aren't more expensive
and it is harder to sell those and for
distributors like Whole Foods will not
office but like Kyocera Albertsons or
they might have some selection and it's
really hard to get rid of that and to
gauge how much of their inventory should
be spent on those items and so if this
system can anticipate and be linked with
other stores to kind of know what the
actual or a closer margin of what the
anticipated sale would be then there
would be incentive so that they can drag
those kind of sales nothing about ads
there also is inherently if if you're
using this system and you're really
interested in tracking your purchases
and you know so you have to go to your
store with the membership card that
store that that isn't that is linked to
the system in order to get that
information so the store might be
motivated you know it has a benefit to
the store to encourage you to use this
system because then you're going to want
to make sure most of your purchases
happen at that store
and they've explored it's an interesting
problem of uncertainty in patient-doctor
communication okay so we are a team
uncertainty my name is Louise and we
looked at or settled on that medical
dialogue mapping as sort of the solution
to our overall problem so we started
really big and we looked at the whole
healthcare system we spoke to a bunch of
different people and some of the issues
that we came up with strengths and
shortcomings were we found that the
closed patient-doctor relationship and
the conversations that happened between
them are very key to almost every
medical situation a shortcoming in this
though is that there is no tangible
representation that exists to remember
this conversation or refer to at a later
date the conversations can be stressed
or rushed and patients are often
inundated with new information so it
often becomes necessary to refer these
conversations at a later date but you
might not know what you would need to
remember so uncertainty is inherent so
we decided that we would create an
artifact that records and represents the
doctor-patient dialogue affords
reflection and
to the relevant information and what we
came up with is called meta log this we
feel like this name really represents it
well because it speaks to both the
medical side of things and the dialogue
side of things as well as the mediation
that this device will hopefully provide
some specific goals are to leverage the
strengths of the healthcare system as it
is today not to try to overhaul the
whole system to be subtle enough to not
distract from the dialogue but be
upfront on the table so as not to be a
secretive recording device we wanted to
show the dialogue mapping scheme during
the recording during the conversation
which would enable this to be more
accessible to review after the fact so
what we came up with is a tabletop
recording device this sits in the
doctor's office between the doctor and
the patient and records and maps the
conversation the dialogue between the
two so what you see here is a snapshot
of the interface you see these
directional microphones which are used
to distinguish one speaker from another
in the conversation and you see this
round screen that's actually sloped
downward in a spiral to indicate this
starting point and to indicate the
cyclical nature of medical diagnostics
so to look at the map in a little bit
more detail we map time to the circle so
we start at 0 degrees and move around
you can see the playhead here this
little black bar and the the the forms
on the outside of the dark black ring
correspond to time that the doctor is
talking in the conversation and here I
highlight the doctors primary
interaction which is indicating phases
of the conversation these are phases we
found to be consistent there's a point
where the doctor is gathering data and
collecting symptoms
there's a point where the doctor is
diagnosing and coming up with what he
thinks the problem is and a point where
he's or she is suggesting treatments so
now we look at the patient portion of
this device where we are indicating
times in the dialogue where the
patient's talking and the patient's
primary interaction also relatively
low-resolution
is leaving markers in the conversation
so this yellow button floats along with
the record head and the patient can
press this to leave a breadcrumb in the
conversation that they can go back to
later basically to flag something that
was important the system does generate
one thing which is tracks which
correspond to reversals in conversation
so the doctors talking talking talking
describing something and the patient
then says okay and that marks one track
that you can use to browse afterwards so
to see this in action a little bit time
is ticking the conversation is going
back and forth where in the symptoms
phase the doctor is going to switch to
the diagnosis phase and the patient is
going to decide to mark something in the
conversation as significant and now we
can look at what this is like in the
context of a particular meeting
so how long does it have to be long
because of these dirty
okay so we spoke to a bunch of different
people including medical professionals
and potential users as far as the
patient end goes and so we thought we'd
give you a little idea of our feedback
from an occupational therapist she
thought it was a good idea because in
her work she sees a lot of filtering of
information from doctors notes through
nurses or herself back down to the
patient because the doctor doesn't have
much time to actually explain things to
the patient from a speech pathologist
she thought it was an interesting idea
also could be useful for saving time
rather than having to write things down
and it could be helpful for people who
are having difficulty remembering things
from a potential patient who said it's a
more effective way of note-taking
without losing the big picture of the
conversation so how we got there
that's the next step here was it was a
long track that led with this idea of
uncertainty and brainstorming how we can
bring some clarity to this whole idea of
medical healthcare system and we started
off by meeting with the chiropractor and
actually trying to get some data trying
to record a 45-minute conversation of
the treatment process in the
chiropractic scenario and then taking
all that and transcribing that and
pretty much we learned from that is that
transcribing is takes a long time took
us like five hours to record or
transcribe 40 minutes of conversation
that people are going to highlight
whatever they find important out of that
mess and that and that that the audio is
really a lot more key than than just
having the text in context so we then
took all of that information plugged it
into a couple different ideas that we
were looking at like this many eyes here
which is an online web browser we
plugged all the transcription into that
to look for repetition in words to see
if there's any patterns in that and and
it didn't seem to bring too much clarity
so what we the one thing we did get was
that there was this back-and-forth
dialogue going between the doctor and
the patient and we could use some
structure with that so we went back
through mapped out more of the process
of the doctors and the patient the
patient going through this process with
the doctor and in thought we could bring
some struction to the conversation there
we came up with the cycle of the the
data collection the hypothesis
essentially and then the implementation
out into the real world and then
possibly refinement as well if you don't
achieve success in the first cycle
through there we did some mapping of
sentence structure and actual audio in
that with this cycle and did our
scenario building here as you saw
earlier and ended with or started this
rough prototype here and then ended with
meta log
yeah so that's definitely one of the
biggest things we started looking at at
first initially we looked at oh so the
question was why we chose the circle to
map time as instead of doing it in a
linear fashion and and we thought there
was a bigger correlation between time
the circle and as it stands as a clock
and that we could use this to calibrate
first off it would probably not
necessarily fill out we imagined that it
would record for up to an hour so and
then it could expand itself to fill up
the circle after the symptoms phase was
done but it could calibrate itself if
it's a got to like two thirds we
definitely looked at doing it in a
linear fashion at first and then
potentially like compressing it to the
circle to map it around time if we
wanted to but we thought actually seen
it grow over time would be more powerful
Henry
so the question is is how does this
relate to patient privacy issues and
liability issues malpractice issues in
in medicine and health care and it's a
big issue it's one that that we can't
totally tackle but we we looked at some
research that's been done in sort of I
don't know high-stakes medicine where
people are being diagnosed with cancer
or where new mothers of infants their
children are being put in intensive care
and some research has been done into
what doctors think about recording these
conversations because you're talking to
somebody telling them they have cancer
they hear the word cancer and they
forget the rest of everything you have
to say so it's actually something using
a regular audio recording device is
something that some doctors have taken a
step forward with and are actually doing
so it's an issue but some people are
trying to say you know no we can address
this by making it upfront by getting
patient agreement and doctor agreement
at the beginning by not doing this in an
incognito sort of way and it's valuable
because it really is useful for people
to go back and refer to these things
later
oh we thought that it could be a
web-based thing so the conversation
could be uploaded and some sort of
freeware could be downloaded on the
patient and on their personal computer
so it would be almost the exact same
interface but they would be able to
highlight certain they would be able to
expand the markers and highlight certain
areas of the conversation or export it
to an mp3 but it would basically be
nearly the same interface there would
also be the option to review previous
conversations and we envision the
spiral-like
visualization for that so the question
one more time was how would somebody
review this and you know within the
within the constraints of the timeframe
we decided to focus on the recording in
the building because if that makes sense
to people then it's it's much easier to
decompose it and access it afterwards I
think that the key piece of our point of
view here is that we want to filter
people back feed people back to the
audio recording and not reveal
transcripts or auto-generated anything
so in some ways the review would be more
standard jumping from track to track and
moving your playhead around we're just
trying to provide pathways avenues to
get into the conversation to make this
audio recording accessible and not
monotonous to dive into alright I'm
going to do as anyone who's transcribed
the conversation knows I'm sure you've
transgressed a few anybody else
the doctor would it be something that
they'd say
we've talked about the possibility of
sharing the conversation between
different or multiple doctors and we
thought that that could be really
beneficial and a diagnostic and
treatment process but we honestly didn't
really go into legality issues that much
as far as who would own the conversation
a question that would have to be
explored the device is something that
would sorry the question is who would
own the device or the okay who's the
user of this product no um so we
envision this as something that lives in
the doctor's office because we thought
that was a good way to sort of bridge
the legal divide between and we don't
want this to be something that patient
brings in and records the conversation
with instead this is the doctor inviting
the patient to access this recorded
conversation after the fact so I guess
the the buyer would be the doctor the
user would be both though
well if the question is who is it for
you know who benefits from this I think
the answer is both and hopefully
everyone on the doctors side there were
a couple comments we referenced about
how this could increase efficiency how
this could save them time and help
improve coordination amongst multiple
people in the doctor's office and on the
patient side people said that they
thought this would be a really
interesting way to pull together
information and take notes during a
conversation without distracting
themselves by taking the notes so we
think there's value on both sides as far
as like a business sort of thing goes I
mean I could see this being something
that if patients are choosing a new
doctor that could be a factor because
the patient can't say I want you to buy
this device but they could you know be
aware of the fact that this device
exists in that doctor's office so next
team is team medical personal medical
records and it's actually an interesting
project where they looked at
record-keeping for individuals so
Microsoft recently acquired a company
called a 6e that has been optimizing
medical record-keeping for hospitals and
turns out that the steam here explored
what it would look like if an individual
would start keeping track for their
personal records
this one okay
hi this is a team personal medical
records the Steve Huard
Michael Lin is Wow and we decided to
create a medical record visualization
tool walk you through the state of your
medical records quick user research some
of our solution a scenario and the
future so what we've created is a
platform for collecting storing and
displaying a person's consumers medical
records over time okay so the current
state of medical records in relation to
the consumer is that it's a mess out
there it's a forest as analogy right now
medical records are everywhere but where
the consumer really can use them usually
they're locked up in a doctor's office
either in paper form inside of them in
manila folder or sometimes they're in
digital form but nonetheless they're
usually with the doctor the good news is
that medical records are becoming more
fluid by the day in about two to three
years about sixty percent of medical
records will be in digital form so we
feel safe assumption that we'll be
working with digital medical records the
bad news is that even when they are in
digital form there are still pretty much
just raw numbers sometimes it's a
thousand page PDF of all these scanned
documents but usually consumers even if
they do get a hold of these medical
records for themselves they can't make
sense they can get a big picture of it
all it's just too much raw data so we
did some user research we did some
interviews with people with consumers
that do have medical records paper
medical records within their house and
they expressed big interest in this type
of project having more control having a
larger picture at their fingertips about
their medical record
so here's the solution we come up with
da so the solution would be create like
a familiar navigation map like a tree
ring or a cross section of a tree if you
will that would grow outwards over time
origin being your birth and then you'd
be use it to spot trends in your health
history and maybe learn about a personal
medical situation but the principle
concept was that were it would organize
your medical history into a searchable
platform so that you can see the big
picture firstly bring in any vector of
your health that you wanted to our
scenario would be that this a guy we
cited his name's Keith ORS in the New
York Times recently had a heart attack
unfortunately at 35 and a set that one
close to 45
he thought he's doing the right thing he
was exercising reducing his weight
unfortunately stopped taking the
medication which it wasn't really
alerted that that was a problem he felt
he had to we feel that if he had a
medical record visualization tool that
he would actually be able to prevent
this so imagine that his doctor provide
him with the tool he'd assigned ranges
for his heart risk like cholesterol
blood pressure some commonalities and
then even if Keith had liked electronic
tracking at home maybe just buy a cuff
cholesterol checking electronic tool he
would be able to launch into this
program and at the data
okay so what we have here is the
beginning of the setup process Keith or
logs in he creates an account with this
a healthcare provider and he logs in so
then he can download his records from
his Hospital in the same way that
quicken might download records from a
bank so here he's importing some medical
records that already existed in stockers
office and now he's he's on his home
computer so he can take a look he wants
to take a look at how is jogging has
been helping helping his health
so what's launching the main menu here
and a few things that you may notice is
that the data is laid out so that at the
center of this tree-ring analogy we have
here the center is the oldest data where
at the edges it's the newest data also
we've got what we call status lights
around the edges so medications it looks
like it's red we might have a few
conflicting medications there
additionally vitals is also red so we
might have some vital signs that are in
unhealthy ranges so and lastly we've got
the bright and dim green lights in the
center near the center which indicate
how frequently these have been updated
for example we may not have had a
doctor's appointment in quite some time
but it looks like we do have very
frequently updated medication vitals and
habits all that data is very new so
let's go into vitals to find out how our
jogging spin affecting everything else
so we're gonna compare a few graphs here
we going we're going to find out our
cholesterol blood pressure as well as
our weight where those are at then we're
going to go down a section down to
habits were jogging and all that
exercise will be so then we just click
on jogging and we we want to generate a
report so we can compare them all and we
just shipped down so here's the actual
graph you were left as the center of the
tree-ring okay so it looks like we've
got we've been jogging pretty well it's
actually been helping the weight quite a
bit however the cholesterol in the blood
pressure for some reason are still going
up we we want to find out why has that
symbol still been going up even with all
this jogging that we he thought would
help so what we did to since comparing
graphs and special
knowing which graphs is more of a power
user task or something that a doctor
might do we introduced a feature called
presets so these presets are just
clusters of graphs that all sent around
a common theme they all they might all
affect each other for example an
exercise preset might contain weight
exercise duration and heart rate so
let's go into our doctors preset that he
recommended for us and let's see it'll
show cholesterol blood pressure and oh
he wants us to look at medications
Keith actually stopped taking
medications about three months ago so
that has had a serious effect on his
cholesterol and blood pressure from here
on out he recognizes that medications
don't can't be substituted by just
exercise alone so he's going to start
back on some medications and he's going
to talk to his doctor about really how
those medications play a role in his
health so in our scenario Keith goes
back to his doctor and talks to him
about the velum or comprehensive plan he
wants to use this tool to help him you
know stand behind his own personal
medical discoveries to improve his own
exercise nutrition medical education
options as doctors empowered to help him
happy ending
Keith prevents a second heart attack
he's found a user group to work with and
he feels empowered to make changes to as
well okay so we feel that there is a
large area that this this can be used in
getting the medical records into the
consumers hands there's already lots of
companies that are doing something near
this for example revolution health is
doing something near this but we've what
we found is that those companies are
doing
missing one of two things either there's
they're missing the automatic
downloading from the doctor's office
revolution health for example requires
that the user enter everything their
blood type everything manually so that's
missing a lot additionally there's other
companies that are are downloading all
this information from the doctor's
office and getting it into the consumers
hands but it's still just raw data still
just just these raw numbers listed
of cholesterol what-have-you users can't
glance at it they can't get the big
picture really quickly so here's some
product expansion areas that this can
also go into for example we can
incorporate a family tree we can find
out the genetic information that is uh
and conditions that are common
throughout the family we could also add
in this can be a platform for more than
just medical information it can contain
personal mementos perhaps and become a
living will of sorts and it also can
support better and more automatic
logging and updating it already does
support things such as the Apple Nike
exercise sensor so it can be a general
platform for any type of medical
information that would relate to your
health for example it contain voice
recordings from your doctor perhaps
anything that would help and knowing
where your health is that so yeah
there's been a lot of companies already
going to this area well on one hand it
could be viewed as competition on the
other hand it can also be viewed as
validation for this area that people
really do want to see their their
medical records where they're at where
their health is at they don't want to
see it every six months wanting to go to
the doctor they want it at their
fingertips so we feel that there is a
great need for this product
any questions
and then being able to cool thing that I
get
so we doctor
my medicine you do it IV that that was a
bit of a there's some interesting thing
to be done there how do we
yeah so the question was how how do
people know where to even look at what
what might be causing this the sudden
spike in one area or another what what
graph should I be looking at to find out
where something might be going wrong
part of that at least is the preset part
is that that was a kind of a group of
graphs that were set by the doctor the
doctor said hey you've got to watch your
medications your cholesterol all that
just kind of assign a healthy range
either get it from the National Board of
Health that's also part of the status
lights the status lights tell you these
big big areas that the Act is warning
warning signs saying hey there's
something wrong with your medications
it's red it might be conflicting
medications you go into further it'll
tell you more about that but it's a
quick glance at it and you can see where
where the areas need to be paid
attention to so that's two areas that
hopefully will contribute to more of a
Oh an awareness more of a direction of
where the users should be looking we
would agree that's a leap too to think
that you're analyzing this on your own
and you're gonna all sudden know exactly
you know what to bring in and how to
study it but we thought it was kind of
like a private practice or doctor doctor
you know presented to land potentially
then you at least get it initialized
based upon your current condition maybe
you maybe you are a heart patient so you
patient so you are really cognizant of
the fact that you need to do stuff about
this and so the hope is that okay now
you start playing with it but then like
you have the other program you're like
okay maybe I should go actually go where
the doctor told me to and so when you
hit the preset then you find out that oh
it's asked me for medication input and I
didn't even I blew off my medications
like mr. do it so no so we did think
about that and this it poses a challenge
our feedback was mostly from people in
the computer industry looking at the UI
so we we haven't actually brought the
the you are to a position yet no we had
researched a bit about what as IXY is
doing so we know that there is lots of
data out there that is machine readable
so at least from a technical standpoint
we believe that this is feasible to
import from the doctor's office whether
we whether doctors are favorable of
consumers having this much control or
not not as much control but more of a
dude yourself type of aspect we did not
research into that area
right I think yeah the answer questions
about feedback and comment about
feedback and it's true that we do need
to present this to a physician now we do
but what like what we are saying about
our validation is it you know there's
right yes we did actually do a usability
study we specify our we went with a user
that had already had paper records in
their home so we know that that is a
potential user they do want to keep
track of their health his wife has
already dealt with cancer so they do
want to find out where all of their
health is at so that was also a bit of
the usability with the UI but they did
express a need for keeping a better
track and consolidation of all these
paper medical records so that was during
an early prototype phase that we did
this with and additionally with that we
found some really keep our users out
there who did have like a thousand-page
PDF of their records over the last 20
years and they individually searched
terms with keywords so that they could
see trends and then they tagged they
brought in like images and one of our
users actually bought a 20 year old
image to his recent heart evaluation and
he said it was very pertinent so the
doctors see it over time and you know we
also we talked to well there are other
individuals that we spoke know that
we're like another guy that actually
researched a company across the country
or Duke University across the country to
get a surgery on his shoulder and he
without his own individual research he
wouldn't have had that opportunity worth
that we are hoping that these kind of
power users would lead the way towards
collecting your own data and then the
question is would the UI like this be
the most
visual important format for them to
store it
but the next next team is up as a team
don't panic and they looked to stress in
high school situations
all right good afternoon everybody we
are team don't panic this is Christine
Komatsu she's a junior in design studies
my name is Chris I'm a senior and
technical technical communication at the
University of Washington our project
here today is focusing on stress so our
audience are teenagers aged 13 to 19
we chose teenagers because teenagers are
going through a tumultuous development
cycle in this stage of their life so
they've got a lot of pressure on
themselves they've got school exams you
need to study for
they've got SATs need to take college
applications to fill out choosing
college or deciding to go on to work
after school they may also have a lot of
responsibilities extracurricular
activities and this is a stage in their
life where they're taking on all these
new responsibilities they're going
through a lot of awkward changes and
forming new relationships with with boys
and with girls and it's a pretty
stressful time in a person's life they
may or may not have the skills that are
necessary to prepare them for adulthood
so our problem statement here is to help
teenagers manage stress in a way that
prepares them to succeed in adult life
so as Chris said stress comes from a lot
of different places and our approach to
our design solution to the teenage
demographic is to incorporate time
management and social networking in the
form of a fashion accessory wristband
and the reason why we do this is to make
this interaction is unobtrusive and
integrated as seamlessly into a
teenager's life as possible also we know
that there are a lot of different
devices like cell phones and I have you
that incorporate you know calendars this
is we've kind of chosen to do and
different things like that but the
do it in a way that these functions are
secondary functions so they're treated
as secondary functions what we wanted to
do was highlight the importance of
stress management and so we made we made
a device specifically for this and we
also believe that this device should
really be an enjoyable experience again
something that's integrated seamlessly
in their lives and we also have a
sliding cover a touchscreen and Chris
will talk about more right okay so
there's two main components to our
project we wanted to give teenagers the
ability to succeed by managing their
time properly and managing that time
resource so there's a calendar so you
can use Outlook or iCal or whatever you
choose to manage your time properly to
make sure that you keep on top of your
schedule and your events but also to see
how you're spending your time if you are
spending too much or too little time on
your schoolwork or if you're you know
spending enough time with your friends
and your family the other component is a
social networking component so teenagers
don't have to feel alone with all of
these stresses and all these burdens
that they may have from school they can
reach out to their peers and form deep
meaningful relationships with one
another and feel comfortable as a
community so the social networking is
also to make sure that it's more than
just sending messages or posting
pictures on the internet it's about
bringing that real-life interaction into
the physical realm and we have a
prototype I'm going to show
okay alright so we have our rough
prototype here and the default view is
the monthly calendar so no surprises
here
the top row is the navigation among the
different components of the wristband
and the second row is a navigation from
viewing your friends in your network so
you have five people in your network
which is a large enough group that you
can get to know people but small enough
that you can feel like you have an
impact on another person's life and you
can be accountable and responsible for
your small network of friends so you can
you know navigate the calendar like a
like a regular calendar you can click on
a day to find more about the day's
events and you it's a touchscreen
interface so you would you touch the
wristband and be able to navigate that
way so for the network you'd be able to
look at your friends profiles and see
what their current status is you could
update that on your computer on Facebook
and you can also see what your friends
schedules are up in the Attic at a
glance to see what's going on and
communicate with them sort of form
friendships and develop this sort of
deep and meaningful relationships in a
real space so we have a one plausible
scenario here oh and I forgot to show
you guys this is up some more renderings
of our wristband boom that's the the
cover open so say we have Jim and he is
playing some songs at a open mic night
on a Friday nights he wants to invite
his friends cannot support in so he gets
on his computer logs on to Facebook and
makes an event sends out invites so his
friends receive the information on their
wristband and they all are notified
about this new events with a new message
one of his friends in the desk in his
Network pile sees the events and he sees
that there's new information so he
decides to check his calendar and he
notices that he's available so he he
feels welcomed by his friends and he
decides to go onto the computer later
that day and RSVP he also sees on his
calendar that his friend Chloe has a
track meet coming up so when he logs on
the computer he decides to send her a
message and she receives it on a
wristband something along the lines of
good luck at your track me you're gonna
do great kick butt and Chloe feels like
there's people out there that care about
her and that she's not so isolated from
her friends and so with our product we
really wanted to facilitate a sense of
community that allows teams to really
develop accountability and
responsibility among each other and the
heart the heart of our project is really
a human interaction aspect of us of the
device not so much I'm sorry human
interaction between with each other not
so much the device the device enables
them to interact with each other and to
be able to reach out and one of my
interviews girl told me that the most
important thing is knowing that someone
is always there and people can't always
be with you 24/7 so this wristband
enables you know messages to come to you
and you can ignore them or look at them
when you want to as teens share their
schedules and their calendars and what
they're what they're doing in their
lives they're able to make their
situation but making the invisible
visible and making connections in this
way also we thought this is really
important to tackle these issues as a at
this age of the teenage demographic beef
to prepare them for adulthood because in
our lives we struggle with stress
forever I mean until we die right and so
it's helpful for we felt that there was
a real need for this and this was our
project
right so the question was why did we
choose a wristband instead of a cell
phone well I don't know if I mentioned
this I kind of like out but there's a
lot of different devices like you know
cell phones are mp3 players that
incorporate calendars and things like
that but like I said they're secondary
applications so you know who has raised
their hand if you have an iPod a lot how
many of you use your calendar no one
yeah
so by using this by creating its own
form I guess with with our core yeah
device we're highlighting the importance
of it and we're making it known I mean
people are teens can use it and you know
it's not hidden and nestled into a
device it's making it visible to teens
so yeah I think I understand that
there's kind of a push in the technology
industry to converge all on one device
that does everything and I guess it
would be feasible to see something like
this pop up on a device like that in the
future when there's more advanced
technology and people are using one
device for well all their mp3s and
phones and communication
so I guess the question was two parts
right how are these people chosen in the
network and how do we ensure that these
isn't a stressful situation by choosing
people right so we wanted to say to that
we would use a social networking site
like Facebook perhaps they've opened up
their API to make interesting
applications so I think it's go ahead
Facebook it they I guess they have high
school networks now so when you are when
you apply or when you connect to this
device your your peers are going to be
the peers in your network and also I
should say that there are limitations
you can't guarantee that you're not
going to get weird people or people that
you know may be abusive and that happens
but in the broad in the bigger picture
we're trying to facilitate a really
healthy network and network that enables
teenagers to help relieve their stress
before it becomes unmanageable and if
that really answers your question but um
you know again there are limitations
right so on Facebook on Facebook you can
join a network of people in your school
or people who have the same interests as
you
so we figured the people could use
Facebook to find other people that
they're interested in or you know maybe
some friends they have at school and I
think making friends is a pretty pretty
stressful situation - it's you know
talking to people that you don't really
know but it's sort of opening up
yourself and you can you know control
privacy with the things on Facebook and
you can choose to share what information
you want so that way you don't have to
feel like there's so much information
being revealed about yourself and I
think too that there's a lot of this
desire has to come from within a person
to want to go out there and meet people
or you know do things together or you
keep track of their time and you know
we're trying to facilitate that
interaction and make it a little bit
easier
right so the question was possible
outbound communication we just mentioned
that right now we're thinking of a
viewer so maybe it would vibrate on the
wrist if there was a new message or new
information but um in terms it's not an
input device it would strictly just be
something that you would receive if you
wanted to input messages or what have
you you would go to your computer you
pick with it so it'd be easily easily
accessible it's conceivable that they
could have a touchscreen keyboard and
then when you hover over it with your
finger the keys blow up so you could see
more but the the pollen tear is a lever
clever word and it's a team of six and
they did the work of six
all right there thanks for the tech
support all right yeah we are the
corporate behemoth of the group here
with six full students in our in our
cohort here so my name is Chris Martin
this is Craig panthan and also on the
roster Jacqueline Knapp
Zach crane Brian Smith and Matt carthan
so what we've developed is the Pollan
tearing Network and you know we took a
really I guess a little bit of a
non-traditional view of health and
wellness and that we wanted to approach
health and wellness from the standpoint
of communities our point of view sort of
being that you really can't be healthy
as an individual unless you're part of a
healthy community and so what does that
mean for a community to be healthy how
how can you improve that that community
health in some way so we started
focusing around something that's already
there that we sort of viewed as being
healthy positive activity in communities
which is volunteering and so we set out
some sort of broad goals that I think
that we've been pretty true to from the
very beginning one increase the
community health and connect
connectedness through volunteering and
hopefully design a fairly novel system
to connect people to volunteer events in
kind of a new way that allows them to
integrate it into the course of their
everyday life volunteering is out there
a lot of people are doing it
we'll talk a little bit about what we
found out about why why not people
volunteer in the first place but I
wanted to give you just a glimpse of our
solutions sort of in a nutshell so we've
we've landed on we started kind of with
this this romantic idea of spontaneous
volunteering and that you know these
kind of smart mobs of people being able
to all serendipitously show up and do
something good in the community like
maybe clean a park or rescue a kitten or
something we ended with something maybe
a little bit more more complicated but
hopefully maybe more realistic as well
and and that is a mobile sort of
proximity based way for people to share
information about volunteer events in
their community there's sort of two
is that will develop here one is the
community sort of being given a voice to
be able to ask its members for help by
offering volunteer opportunities and
then on the other side participants
these potential volunteers being able to
carry the announcements of these
volunteer opportunities sort of like
digital pollen brushing them off on
other people in their communities who
also share like interests so a little
bit about some of our initial research
we obviously wanted to find out a lot
about why people are volunteering
interestingly we found out there there's
a high degree of intention for
volunteering a lot of people have the
positive and maybe a lot of people in
here think about volunteering from time
to time but when we sat down and and
talked to people about their volunteer
experiences and maybe why they're not
doing it anymore we found a lot of
people who that who had something in
their past but you know it was like the
Boys and Girls Club that they did when
college and now they're professionals
and they don't have time and what if I'm
on Saturday I have to take my car into
the shop I don't want to commit three
weeks ahead of time to you know do the
big brother and sister thing some people
just kind of didn't know where to start
you know there's a lot of stuff out
there if you go to volunteer match and
you type in I'm interested in education
in this area code and there's like 300
different things and it looks a bit like
you know monster.com for voluntary kind
of a friendly atmosphere for identifying
these things in the first place well why
do pie people volunteer you know what's
what's sort of the positive side of this
we found something really interesting
from from some data and some study is
that volunteering is really driven by
asking 50 percent of people who are
asked to volunteer actually do volunteer
and then of the volunteers of people
that are sort of labeled as active
volunteers about 70 percent of those got
started in volunteering than this in the
first place because somebody asks asked
them you know so the potential is there
the energy there's a lot of potential
energy just not necessarily all the
kinetic energy that we need there's also
something kind of surprising and that
you know volunteering is a very social
activity there are people that said you
know I volunteer when I have the chance
to go do it with friends there's a much
more like it's much more likely that I'm
going to go to an event if I know
someone's going to be there it sounds
like a party kind of but you know in
some ways I guess it is and then sort of
a side observation that that we noted as
we were
and yet trying to understand community
health and you know all of the negative
messages that we get about the health of
our communities is that there there
really isn't a great outlet for what you
can actually do about them right there
at the point when you're understanding
and being given sort of the bad news
from the newspaper about about what's
going on in your community so let's
explore our project a little bit through
the use of scenario common theme in
these presentations so this is Aaron
Aaron
she lives in Green Lake as you know is a
nice little neighborhood here in Seattle
she's a lab technician at PSC they do
all kinds of interesting recycling of
dangerous products she she has a lot of
fun with her friends likes to go to the
bowling alley pretty good average
actually but she's diversified in her
recreational interest she's on a
kickball league as well and so one day
we're gonna take this sort of a day in
the life she's on her way to the grocery
store walking there on the sidewalk
checking out the latest headlines and
she notices that there's this dynamic
display that's that's positioned there
next to the newspaper boxes and she's
you know curious to find out what this
thing actually looks like so what we're
gonna see here is sort of what she's
seeing this is you know an announcement
of the pollen tearing Network in a map
of her community and as time is going by
we're getting a view of the upcoming
week and the volunteering opportunities
that are occurring throughout her
neighborhood
we've also sort of incorporated this
framework for community health that we I
guess borrowed from from the Seattle
Foundation which sort of breaks down
different needs in the community along
basic needs medical care education arts
and culture the environment and civic
engagement and so we found that those
were also nice little buckets for a lot
of the volunteer opportunities to fit
into so she's interested in this in fact
there was a prompt at the bottom of the
screen that said you know if you want to
find out more connect with your
Bluetooth to this particular ID code and
so she goes ahead and does that and
we're gonna take a look at the
introductory video that plays on her
phone to give her a little more
information about this system so every
day there are opportunities to make a
difference in your community this
dynamic sign offers your community a
voice to express
it's needs tune into specific events
based on what you care about and when
you're available like digital palling
you share the information with others by
simply moving amongst your community
through intersections and interactions
the information spreads and spreads
culminating in a populated event and a
better community so she's in given the
opportunity to download the software
that enables her to be a part of this
community and so she continues on to the
grocery store or she does her shopping
perhaps taking the content into account
some of the environmental impacts that
the products might have and while she's
in line she decides she's gonna set the
software she basically sets a few
preferences about things that she's
interested in which of those categories
are most appealing to her and
immediately as she puts her phone down
another person walks by and a volunteer
event sort of jumps onto her phone as a
piece of digital pollen so she notices
that and she takes her phone to take a
look at you know what this what this
interface is actually gonna look like
and she's presented with pretty much a
simplified calendar again you're getting
a fairly nice luxurious view but we were
designing for a fairly small screen here
and so she's able to scroll back and
forth each of these boxes representing a
week and she's particularly interested
in the environment based on her job and
she takes a look at what opportunities
are available locally here in the
environmental category so she sees one
friends of green lake stream restoration
who looks particularly interesting she's
able to peruse it get some more details
find out some contact information and
then it is either to sign up bookmark it
to save it for later invite a friend or
delete it from her little roster so well
we'll catch up with Erin now a day later
she's in a coffee shop and reading one
of her favorite books and someone in the
coffee shop happens to pick up one of
those events because they share a common
interest in the environment and just
then someone parks their car outside and
has a few other volunteer events that
jump onto her phone as
digital pollen starts to propagate
throughout the community and this time
her phone starts vibrating and so she's
really interested to find out you know
as she's exploring this new interface
what might this mean
so she we're gonna get to take a look at
what what the interface would show now
all right so you know here we have I
think well there's a new event here
that's in the in the education category
and so she's able to go explore what
that new event is and she sees that you
know there's sort of this pulsing
pulsing light here and the reason why is
that one of her friends that's been
defined in her network actually used to
have this very piece of digital pollen
on her phone and pollinated the network
with it back on May 22nd and so this is
kind of interesting now that she knows
that her friend has actually seen this
event and she might call her up a little
bit later see if she wants to go with
and check out the event she also saw
there was another new event at them the
basic needs category so she decides to
check that out while she's here and sees
that this meal preparation event has has
occurred and she knows that one of her
friends is a great cook and would
probably be interested in checking this
event out so she goes ahead and invites
her friend so we'll see her friend here
a dashing fellow in the laundromat picks
up the event and says yeah this is great
I want to sign up for this particular
event and while he's folding his laundry
you know this the the saga continues
that that volunteer opportunity is able
to move on so at the end of the day
she's walking back to her house and as
she passes the sign a fresh load of
volunteer opportunities jumps from sort
of this main source into her phone and
she continues as active member in the
network so what are some of the
implications of this kind of this
network in this design and so we you
know we we thought about this what one
thing is that every participant now sort
of becomes this silent advocate for the
things that they care about it kind of
changes your relationship to
volunteering in some ways not to promote
laziness and not to show up to events
but you do have this sense that even if
I'm not always showing up and going and
participating and picking up the shovel
on the rake
I am having a role in encouraging
positive activity within my community
there there is something also about this
having kind of a very safe bridge
between the anonymity that exists in
communities and between strangers you
know it's a way of sort of revealing
something about yourself and finding
something out about the people around
you without necessarily having to get
all their personal information and be
able to trace their name and their
address and such things and there's also
I think this concept that we really
related to which was that the data kind
of lives within the communities at this
point and and these pieces of digital
pollens start to accumulate a history
and traces throughout throughout the
communities and among the people that
that they carry through and and and
something I kind of alluded to is that
you know this now becomes sort of this
detection device as you see things
populate into these different categories
you can understand the the the crowd
around you might be particularly
interested in environmental concerns or
might be particularly interested in
basic needs and that's kind of an
interesting indicator of place so
finally I just want to leave you with a
few reflections one is we acknowledge
right away there's certainly more
efficient ways to distribute digital
information namely the Internet and
that's that's not necessarily what our
goal was here was to compete with that
and trying to make this the the be-all
end-all way of finding about volunteer
opportunities but I think that there's
something interesting that happens when
information sharing is based upon
people's proximity to each other and it
raises some questions about you know
what might this mean to their sense of
connection to other people to places to
events how might this you know actually
change some things or enhance some
things about this area of context of
where computing that that's sort of
coming online right now so we found this
exploration really valuable I think that
overall we've you know introduced a
model that possibly could have
applications to other areas and other
other types of information but for now
hopefully this is this might be one that
could actually improve community health
and wellness Thanks
yes absolutely
so I mean part one of the screenshots we
didn't show was sort of this ability to
kind of filter things based on your
preferences and so there of course you
get it one one level of filtering
happens there we look to see you know
how much how many volunteer opportunity
and and for a given you know week it's
it's probably in the range of a couple
of hundred and the way that these
databases are currently controlled is
that you I think they're pretty much
through registered nonprofit
organizations are able to input this
information in databases so there's some
level of control there and I think that
we we all kind of initially had this
vision of you know like getting on to a
crowded bus and all of a sudden your
phone starts going crazy with all this
stuff but I think we kind of and without
we haven't really been able to test that
but I think the the other possibility
would be that in fact there really
aren't that many things represented in
your local neighborhood in terms of
volunteer opportunities and this is a
sort of a fun way to find out about what
other people are doing and connect to
your friends as they do them so that and
that's a good thing to keep remember is
that this by this initial sign that you
get this software from kind of
designates your your community so that
geographic limitation like Chris was
saying reduces that of opportunities in
Seattle there's hundreds of
opportunities available every you know
every week but when you start limiting
it down at these compartmentalize areas
it reduces it significantly and you're
choosing different interest areas so if
you're only choosing three out of the
six then you're much better off but of
course there's always the danger of
cross-pollination and you know and some
guy flies in from Detroit and and starts
starts loading all these these needs for
poor Detroit you know that's something I
guess we'd have to sort of build into
the preference-sensitive yeah
well yeah I haven't done the the cost
analysis yet I am encouraged by the
falling falling prices of a touchscreen
and perhaps Microsoft would want to
donate some tabletop displays some
searching a dual touch surface displays
to be able to accommodate such a noble
cause I think that's actually more a
function of our fantastic industrial
designers able to mock-up things that
look really expensive in fact you know
we could probably get by with some some
cheaper materials no anything we see we
have we remain me do keep in mind we're
the ten weeks
Thanks
all right thank you
well last and certainly not least though
we've got the team after the break
they always get to present a thought
it's time this is actually a very
special team its consists of two
engineers that were brave enough to
wander over to the art design world of
u-dub and they looked at nutrition and
eating together the aspects of food and
health and I think they came up with a
really great design so enjoy the last
presentation yeah as you know just feel
free to stretch during our presentation
and won't bother us we're a little used
to it
my name is Jacob I'm Dave this is Dave
and I'll tell you a little bit about
what we came up with maybe okay as we
were introduced to engineers so we
wanted to tackle the problem that we saw
as a big one no pun intended of American
eating and obesity and we kind of looked
at it through the lens of our typical
background and we wanted to provide a
solution that was low in cost highly
accessible to all the people that wanted
to use it and promoted a social aspect
and we also defined these saw these as
being the problems that we're currently
driving bad eating trends right now
and so our core premise was that two
things really even if you're eating bad
if you're eating in smaller portions
you're going to be okay not necessarily
okay but better off and if you're
cooking your own meals you're less
likely to prepare it in an unhealthy
fashion so those are the two things we
really wanted to drive it
so we went through a lot of ideation
trying to find out how we could address
all these problems came up with a lot of
great ideas but at the end of the day
that was our favorite one but they
didn't like it if you have if you have
any questions after the presentation on
some of the more fun ideas that we came
up with we'd be more than happy to
elaborate on those but our solution
ended up being a virtual type diner and
the idea behind this was like I said
imagine being a person out on your first
date if you can remember that and that's
kind of our prototypical user is a young
professional people that are tech savvy
people like that um you're not if you're
involved in conversation with someone
you're not necessarily going to Gorge
out on the 24-ounce t-bone steak in the
12 inch high death by chocolate cake so
on we came up with this way to bring
people together and you can see all of
our ideas on it here but we'll kind of
just dive into it to give you a better
idea of what we're talking about right
so our user the simple life of sausage
man that's a username
he's young a professional basically
we're thinking of a yuppie someone who
goes to work most of the day and then
comes back home he's just mentally
exhausted and you know he needs to get
his food in right so it's for a 3:45
p.m. sausage man's mentally exhausted
he's is still in the office so he wants
a 10 minute break or something so he
goes to diner on our software all right
this is our front page yeah sure so lots
of stuff going on here but to highlight
a few of the main points you'd come into
this this would be exciting this would
be a place you'd go back to again and
again it would have like June's
asparagus month for instance so ways to
get involved with things event
like that we would encourage interaction
through a points-based system and you
could this is you know your prototypical
website design but you could also we
also envision having a virtual kitchen
that you could build from the ground up
as an alternate way to navigate the site
but as you use the site more you would
gain points and you'd be able to buy you
know that Viking range for your virtual
kitchen or the Frigidaire fridge or
whatever great commercial tie-ins you
could you know whatever you wanted to do
and in that realm so let's say we log in
and this here were greeted with the
recipe page and our idea was you get
home at the end of the day I want to
make something I have this in my
cupboard I find it I get a nutritional
breakdown of what its gonna be like to
cook this food but the really part we
wanted to drive home with this project
was okay I found this and now as you see
up in the top right here the social
connection comes in this is where it's
this is what sets it apart from all the
other things that are out there Facebook
MySpace those things are great but
they're static recipe websites are great
but they just give you a text printout
of the recipe so this brings everything
together so let's say I've found a meal
that I want to cook and I get this
pop-up that says there's a public pasta
cook-off going on right now that you
could join in that might be fun or
Caliente wants to cook with you and this
I'll let Dave write Caliente
who'd say no anyway so this is a base
what do you want use the calendar very
simple you know everybody's used to
counter that's where it's set up of your
vents and in the future and all that we
have did you oh yes I and then after the
date has been set up you eventually on
the dead you go to the date page so a
couple there's lots of things but the
thing we want to emphasize here is that
you know we're using a video conference
software here so that people can
actually cook together watching a meal
or actually learn how to cook so right
now there's a two people in this room
which is sausage man and Kylie
on their day but it's also the original
recipe video so what's his name again
email right right so if you have prom
like cooking the meal you could always
click on that and you'll be able to see
it one thing really is because we have
the potential of having many users is
that we also want to incorporate the
grid view which is like if you look up
the top left corner of the current
camera bit which is that six square I'm
six rectangles that will let us see all
the users at one time and see all the
videos going at one time but then you
can select which ones you want to see
this would be like you joined a larger
dining hall like the public pasta
cook-off or whatever you would see a
bunch of people up there and you could
always you could scroll between the
different views of people that were
cooking at that same particular time all
right one thing we realized is that
knowing we don't need all that
information most of the time so there's
the expanded view this is just the two
main portions two modules which is the
current camera which is this much larger
screen for you could interact with the
person and the recipe directions the
things we want to emphasize here is the
rest of our directions this is the
buttons are so much larger now because
when you're when you're in the kitchen
there's like sauce flying all over the
place you don't really want to be able
to pinpoint little small bits on the
screen so we have the made buttons much
bigger during the recipe we realized
that because there are many people who
might be involved right we have a color
feedback on how where the other person
might be on jinda during the course of
the meal so the Reds must represent
where Caliente is right now which is
blowing noodles into softened but you
are currently on the big bring afraid of
sauce your sight boil and then add
noodles thing right so that's easier to
see we also have this options bar which
is like where you go mouse over to see
right and this is actually how we handle
the end of the ordering the conversation
during day so we have the conversation
pieces because this is social networking
app there's you gonna pick up some
information about what they are so you
we've come up with some conversation
pieces for you to talk about to keep the
conversation going there's that
post mortem as you software guys love to
say which is which lets you manage the
experience at the end of the day so we
have a couple of options there and then
there's our give me a star which is our
nutritional and participant point system
where we're trying we incorporate two
different systems of one the points is
to will allow you by like the extra
Viking range for virtual kitchen or the
nutritional rating which is the for
starch which is just give you a general
overview of a user to encourage the
person to eat there alright so the happy
ending our our sausage man has killed 10
minutes of his office time and that's a
great accomplishment he's found a local
haughty and caliente who's he who's he's
excited about cooking with tonight when
he gets home he's cooking himself a
home-cooked meal he's not stopping by
Burger King and sitting in front of you
know the TV to watch American Idol or
something he's gained valuable diner
points which he can use to make his
virtual kitchen better so he can get
more local hottie saying look at this
guy's his awesome kitchen I want to cook
with this guy tonight he's increased his
nutritional rating as the site will keep
track of what you've been cooking and
how often you've been using it and he's
viewed valuable online advertising for
diners profit and this could be via the
Food Network as Emeril Lagasse will be
our first backer what if you choose it
I'll give him the option yeah all right
so if everybody knows Facebook recently
released their API so this is great for
us because all we need to do is pay big
ACK off them we don't have to have
developed a social networking aspect of
it so just imagine this module being on
your Facebook profile we have like just
two pieces information I want to cook we
should let you prep and introduce people
to setting up a date with you and my
favorite recipe all right which is like
more of like oh this is me this I love
to cook this stuff right and we use the
same the same basic features that
Facebook has but we can create we
believe this would increase the amount
of user
we don't have to actually bother getting
uses for this alright so that is our
virtual diner so to speak questions
comments yeah um the thing that really
surprised me the most was the oh sorry
to repeat the question what surprised us
about user feedback when we were showing
this to people the thing that surprised
me the most is the actual the range of
what people were saying
I showed this actually separately to a
boyfriend and a girlfriend so they
already had a they wouldn't need this
for the social networking aspect of it
but they both loved it the girlfriend
was so excited about building her
virtual kitchen that she wanted to cook
on it right then and there and that that
surprised me because that wasn't
something I was expecting that people
would be that excited about it the guy
saw this as a way for him to interact
with his girlfriend a lot better and
that that wasn't even the intent but he
saw this as a way for him to be able to
cook with her and so that was another
user base that we hadn't even seen at
this point in time and so and then of
course now he's motivated to watch the
food network with her and see these
recipes that he can go and like put on
that one thing we didn't really talk
about too much was the recipe book would
be mostly user uploaded recipes we would
start out with a stock recipe set but we
see it as expanding and people would
upload their own recipes and then you'd
get user feedback and that type of thing
another way to gain points or whatever
and so any other questions comments
all right well thank you very much